[Applause]
how you doing thank you for being here
yeah
what are we doing i don't know what
we're doing here but i'll do it too
makes me feel like i want to do that
yeah yeah good all right all right
everybody i like it nice suit by the way
thank you it's made of pure love
i don't know it's cashmere and goat's
blood
[Laughter]
i can't wait for that to be taken out of
context
on the web wow and all worship satan um
the new celebrity trend well welcome to
the show thanks for being here again a
lot to talk about uh first of all um you
of course were nominated last year did
you go to the oscars this year did you
attend i didn't i was actually here
right yeah it was here night was did you
watch them do it i watched them on
television and i i was a little
disturbed by them yeah i was disturbed
mostly with the you know the dance
troupe the the what's their name is it
pelova what i forget what their name was
no it wasn't i don't know
something those they would dance behind
a screen in united hearts and make weird
shapes like it reminded me of like i was
in a dance sort i was invited to be in a
dance concert when i was in high school
and then it kind of reminded me of that
time i i i
i was in it was traumatic yeah
so you were in what kind of dance uh
modern dance troupe you did modern dance
in high school yeah i did i was i was
willing to talk about it now that's
incredible
yeah i'm not holding anything back
anymore right well okay so what made you
uh what made you join the modern dance
troupe well there weren't any guys you
know so they you know i was in
performing arts in high school so they
the girls in the dance company asked me
if i would be in the show right you know
and like just all the things that they
did on the oscars reminded me like all
those weird moves you know those like
there's like those like things that they
do
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot of
that and this like the snakes on a plane
yeah yeah yeah cause like it was like
took me back to high school right so you
freaked me out freaked you out that's
not the oscars
yes it is the oscars
pretty much every year there's so many
units it's like 1975 yeah well did you
have a good time doing that in high
school amazing
hearing about it makes me you should um
it makes me want to yeah
you've got to stop okay
i can help you with this okay now this
must have been nice because your sister
maggie your sister maggie
presented on the oscars
she
four months ago so you're uh you're an
uncle
oh yeah it's great it's amazing except
for the diaper changing which i had um
experience in once and i will never go
back to again until uh usually the uncle
doesn't have to change a diaper i want
to try it out you wanted you actually
wanted to try it out i tried it i wanted
to see what it was like and i'm the same
guy that said i want to join the modern
dance troupe in high school
yeah i want to wear unitard what else
change your diaper maggie hand me the
child yeah i was i just i wanted to try
it out so i my sister likes organics you
know she likes a lot of organic things
so she she she handed me
my niece and and she said go ahead and i
put her down on the changing table and i
unknotted her organic diaper it's an
organic diaper it's made out of bananas
and straw
[Laughter]
oh that's terrible
really unfortunate but not as
unfortunate as what came out of my
nieces behind yeah um
i never knew i really never knew and i
am naive of course but i i never knew
that it was orange and that
i have a very short gag reflex so yeah
when i saw it it was sort of a uh
it was like should i reenact it for you
yeah sure it was like
like that
and and then i sort of just i
like that and handed her back handed the
baby off and then retreated in this way
[Applause]